- Here's a big one.
If you're not feelin' it,
find new friends.
I'm being dead serious about this.
This one is real big for me.
Who you have out with
is a huge deal.
And again, these are all
tried and true things, right?
We've heard the
"You're the whatever of the
"five friends you."
That's real.
That's,
that one,
put in the bank.
Like if you're not
feelin' it,
you need to go to meetup.com
and go to 10 meetups of
people that are hungry.
Like, it's unbelievable
what happened to me
when I got into the Silicon Valley world,
and started meeting like Mark Zuckerberg,
and like, Ev Williams, Sacca, and like
Travis, like,
it changed my life.
This town, actually it's like fun for me
to tell this story here.
SXSW 2007 changed my life, because I,
hung out,
I forced myself to go to a
Web 2.0, which later became
"Social Media, The Current
State of the Internet Conference
"SXSW",
and I was looking at all these kids,
and by the way,
this is when tech wasn't cool,
straight fucking nerds,
but they were trying to change shit.
They weren't here for kicks and giggles.
They weren't here to hook up,
they were here to like,
change the world.
Like I'm gonna build a product
that is going to be in every
single person's hand,
like and they have
like the Twitters, and the Facebooks,
and the Ubers.
They did.
And, it was the biggest
impact of my career.
And it's something I
think a lot about now.
So anyway,
real practical, if you feel motivated
by this conversation,
or you're intrigued by it,
add one new winner friend.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like, you know what I mean?
- [Man] 100 percent.
- Add one new winner friend,
and cut one loser friend.
Like, yeah, I know he's been
your boy since fourth grade,
but he sits at home and
fucking smokes weed,
and plays 2K all day.
- [Man] (laughing)
- Like, you can only love him so much.
Go home, cut one,
cut your loserest, loser friend,
- [Man] (laughing)
and go find a winner friend.
Go like, go somewhere,
go somewhere like,
go to like, go,
go to meetup.com,
go to a Facebook group,
join some shit,
DM the 800 people that you think are,
make sure they're not bullshitting,
they're like, doing what you want,
and just make one new friend.
I see it, like DRock,
like he's like right,
it's unbelievable to watch my team,
like they get faster, they get smarter,
they get more confident, right.
It's real man, it's real.
Confidence, and like hunger,
gets passed onto each other,
its like team dynamics,
it's why like, a great
player that sucks shit
can fuck up a team up.
Like go audit your circle.
Add one more winner,
decrease one more loser.
(uptempo music)